we never know when we might have to do a
little bit more party planning so it
doesn't hurt to have some practice and
that's what this exercise is doing for
us is to giving us generating problems
so that we can try solving systems of
equations with elimination and so this
first problem it says solve for x and y
using elimination and then this is what
they have 6x minus 6y is equal to
negative 24. negative 5x minus 5y is
equal to negative 60. so let me get my
scratch pad out to solve this so let me
rewrite it
so they gave us
6x
6x minus 6y
is equal to negative 24
and
negative 5x
minus 5y
is equal to negative 60.
so what we have to think about and we
saw this in several of the other videos
is when we want to eliminate a variable
we want to manipulate these two
equations that if we were to add the
corresponding sides that variable might
disappear so if we just added a 6x to a
negative 5x that's not going to cancel
it out if this was a negative 6x that
would work out or if this was a positive
5x that would work out but this isn't
exactly right
so if i want to eliminate the x i have
to manipulate these equations so that
these two characters might cancel out
and one thing that pops into my brain is
it looks like all of this stuff up here
is divisible by 6 and all of this stuff
down here is divisible by 5. and if we
divide all the stuff up here by 6 we'd
be left with an x over here and if we
were to divide all this bottom stuff by
5 we'd be left with a negative x right
over here and then they just might
cancel out so let's try that out
let's take this first equation and we're
going to multiply both sides by 1 6.
we're going to multiply by 1 6 or
another way you could think about is
we're dividing both sides by 6.
and as long as we do the same thing to
both sides the equation holds the
equality holds so if you multiply
everything by 1 6 6 x times 1 6 is just
going to be x
6 y times 1 6 is just y so it's negative
y
is equal to 20 negative 24 times 1 6 is
negative 4
negative 4 or you could just view this
negative 24 divided by 6 is negative 4.
so this equation the blue one we've
simplified as x minus y is equal to
negative 4. let's do something similar
with the second one
here we could say we're going to
multiply everything times one-fifth or
you could say that we're dividing
everything by five
if we do that negative five x divided by
five is just negative x
negative five y divided by five is
negative y
and then negative 60 divided by 5 is
negative 12.
and now this looks pretty interesting
if we
add the two left-hand sides and remember
we can keep the equality because we're
essentially adding the same thing to
both sides you can imagine we're
starting with the blue equation and on
the left hand side we're adding negative
x minus y
and on the right hand side we're adding
negative 12 but the second equation
tells us that those two things are equal
so we're doing the same principle that
we saw when we first started looking to
algebra that you can maintain your
equality as long as you add the same
thing on the left hand side we're going
to add this and on the right hand side
we're going to add this but this second
equation tells us that those two things
are equal so we can maintain our
equality so let's do that what do we get
on the left hand side well you have a
positive x and a negative x they cancel
out that was the whole point behind
manipulating them in this way and then
you have negative y minus y which is
negative 2y
and then on the right hand side you have
negative 4 minus 12 which is negative
16 and these are going to be equal to
each other once again we're adding the
same thing to both sides to solve for y
we can divide both sides by negative two
and we are left with y is equal to
positive eight
but we are not done yet we wanna go and
substitute back into one of the
equations and we could substitute back
into this one into this one or this one
and this one the solutions need to
satisfy all of these essentially this
blue one is a another way of expressing
this blue equation this green equation
is another way of expressing this green
equation so i'll go for whichever one
seems to be the simplest and this one
seems to be pretty simple right over
here so let's take x
x
minus y
we just solved that y would be
positive 8 is equal to negative 4
is equal to
negative 4.
and now to solve for x we just have to
add 8
add 8 to both sides
and we are left with on the left hand
side negative 8 plus 8 cancels out
you're just left with an x and negative
4 plus 8 is equal to positive 4. so you
get x is equal to 4
x is equal to 4
y is equal to 8. and you can verify that
it would work with either of one of
these equations 6 times 4 is 24 minus 6
times 8 so it's 24 minus 48 is indeed
negative 24.
negative 5 times 4 is negative 20
minus negative 40 if y is equal to 8
does indeed get you negative 60. so it
works out for both of these and we can
try it out by inputting our answer so x
is 4 y is 8. so let's do that
so let me type this in
x is going to be equal to 4
y is going to be equal to eight and
let's check our answer
it is correct
very good